[Música]
este 19 de junio es una fecha señalada
especialmente para la población
afrodescendiente en Estados Unidos se
celebra o se conmemora el día del
estudiante que habla del fin de la
esclavitud del estado de Texas en el año
1865 después de que el presidente
Abraham Lincoln decretara la
proclamación de la emancipación en enero
de 1863 una fecha desconocida por
décadas para la mayoría de la población
no afro e incluso para parte de la
población afrodescendiente pero que tras
las protestas de Black lives matter ha
vuelto a tomar mucha relevancia hasta el
punto que Joe biden la declaró un
feriado Federal en el 2021 vamos a
ahondar en la significancia de esta
fecha y para ello hablamos con tonilla
hope Ella es la directora del centro de
asuntos internacionales de brunche en el
hogward University Muchísimas gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros
muchas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación Bueno quiero empezar
preguntándole cómo ha sido festejada
esta fecha a lo largo de los años y qué
es lo que este año marca el día
bueno
por muchos años generaciones ha sido una
celebración
dentro de la principalmente dentro de la
comunidad afroamericana en los Estados
Unidos
que se celebra con fiestas con barbecue
con
con una reunión familiar
Pero bueno durante el veintiuno
veintiuno cuando el presidente va a ir
en lo declaró un un día festivo
y ha ganado más visibilidad a nivel
nacional
entre toda la sociedad Norte bueno de
Estados Unidos bueno para usted Cuál
tiene que ser el foco de la celebración
y de la conmemoración En qué deberíamos
estar reflexionando un día como hoy
Bueno yo creo que es un momento de
reflejar en todos los logros que hemos
tenido como como población afroamericana
afrodescendiente en los Estados Unidos
pero es también un momento de reflejar
en todo el trabajo que que nos falta
hacer en los Estados Unidos
a pesar de de todos los obstáculos de
las barreras de las de los leyes
injustos y el racismo institucional
hemos logrado muchas cosas
dentro de todas las disciplinas todos
los sectores de la sociedad pero todavía
falta mucho trabajo
Mucho muchas cosas todavía no van bien
en mi país desafortunadamente bueno
ciertamente la lucha antirracista ha
cobrado cada vez más fuerza y más
relevancia en Estados Unidos pero
también cada cierto tiempo nos
encontramos nuevamente con otro crimen
racista con otro crimen que tiene que
ver con discriminación hacia la
población afrodescendiente porque cree
usted que hay tantas trabas para superar
este digamos bucle de de crímenes
racistas en el país
Bueno
ese es lo que nos queda de del sistema
de racismo de de discriminación que es
parte de la
de la cultura de los Estados Unidos y de
muchos otros países como como vimos hace
poco en su en su segmento sobre
Australia ese el problema de la supreme
supremacia blanco es
parte de nuestra historia a nivel global
y y también especialmente parte de la
historia de los Estados Unidos y eso no
se va a desaparecer porque salimos a las
calles
de vez en cuando eso requiere mucho más
trabajo de parte de todos no solo los
afroamericanos sino toda la sociedad
tiene que decir que ciertas cosas no
está bien que hay que cambiar
leyes hay que cambiar
forma de ser
forma de pensar forma de actuar requiere
la participación de toda la sociedad
Bueno hablemos sobre eso porque aunque
las noticias que vemos Nosotros
comúnmente en los medios de comunicación
tienen que ver con hechos que se vuelven
masivos y que son crímenes muchas veces
fatales hay una serie de agresiones o
microagresiones que estamos cometiendo
todos durante nuestra vida diaria por
favor denos algunos ejemplos Pues de
Cómo ser anti racistas no solamente
Opuestos o decir que no somos racistas
Bueno yo creo que
como dije no no primero no puede ser
solo de trabajo de la comunidad
afrodescendiente tiene que ser el
trabajo de toda la sociedad y uno
siendo no afro debe reflejar en su forma
de interactuar su forma de hablar pensar
si están en una un salón Por ejemplo y
se uno no afro se dé cuenta de que hay
una sola persona en en este salón Por
ejemplo esta persona no debe ser la que
tiene que defender todo tipo de
de ofensas o racista o cualquier
comentario que puede ser tal vez no
cómoda entonces
uno siendo no afro debe darse cuenta y
y no dejar que esa persona afro Tiene
que hablar una persona Blanca por
ejemplo puede decir
cuestionar y preguntar por qué estamos
dirigiendo Esa esa cosa ese comentario
Solo esa persona o por qué Esperamos que
esa persona afro es la que tiene que
responder a ese esa pregunta ese
comentario es el trabajo de toda la
sociedad blancos no blancos etcétera
pues Mireya Yo le agradezco mucho por
entregarnos esta visión que
definitivamente necesitamos interiorizar
muchísimo más y con la intención de
celebrar mucho la estética
afrodescendiente la cultura
afrodescendiente y la cultura
afrodescendiente que al final pues es la
de todos Muchísimas gracias
Gracias
Vamos a continuar hoy con más noticias y
más análisis en directo a América sigan
con nosotros ya volvemos
[Música]